大家好，这里是合同打扰了，我是沙拉。
我是Tomo。
我们在三月节目里聊了一期日本的技术视频，当时因为没有来得及展开讲针对老年人市场的介乎视频，所以当时买了一个伏笔。
想说看看大家对于养老话题的兴趣程度，结果没有想到在评论区里面就看到了听众朋友们挥舞着各种小手。
然后我看到本台听我们真的有非常强烈优幻意识啊。
所以本期节目我们索性就给之前的伏笔来一个再续前院趁热打铁聊一聊日本的养老。
当然这个也算是我们第一次这么快就把自己挖了坑给填上了是吗？
以前都是只管挖坑不管别的是吧？被咱们群友称为无情的挖坑机器。
主要呢咱这不也是巧了嘛，上个月Tomo哥不幸病倒，并且住院了很长一段时间。
想必是充分体验到了身体不变所带来的各种生活不变。
所以先请Tomo哥展开讲讲，在住院和康复这个时间里面你都有什么样的感受和心得？
因为我妈是护士的关系嘛，所以我从小就没怎么去过医院。
就是吃药打针一般都在自己家就解决了。
那这次呢是我人生中第一次手术家住院。
那虽然人过四十谈不上有多老吧，
但是住个院呢还是能切身体会到很多人老之后的不便利。
比如说手上挂着吊瓶，左右腹都插着管子的时候，
就是坐也坐不起来，吃个饭脱个衣服都能把人难哭。
那手术之后第一次下床的时候呢，
就是试图抓住任何能抓的东西来做支撑。
用尽全力好不容易挪到厕所，还差点晕倒在里面。
就是当你健健康康过着再普通不过的每一天的时候，
就真的完全无法想象，身体的衰弱可以让人变得这么无力。
对，过去几年莫名其妙做过两次外科手术的我疯狂颠倒。
那同样也是因为这个人过四十嘛，就是开始面对家人的养老问题。
像爷爷奶奶这一辈儿还有多个姿女可以轮换照顾吗？
那到了爸妈这一辈儿呢，就只剩了这个独生姿女的我们了。
而等我们老了又该怎么办呢？
就是年轻人还足以维持这个社会运转吗？
养老设施还足以迎接老龄化的挑战吗？
这么多问题摆在眼前，真是不赖大家提前操心。
就是上有老，下有小的同时还压不住自己摔老的速度。
就是每天光这个记忆力的衰退都给我烦躁的，
就是每次写有稿都写到丢三大丝。
那说到养老这个问题的话，
其实因为我从小就没有跟老人生活在一起，
包括我老家也回得很少嘛。
所以讲老实话就用目前而言的话，
我对老年生活的实际接触和理解其实是不多的。
但是上一个冬天有一次是因为我要给我外婆买衣服，
她生活在保游区嘛，就冬天又是又冷。
我就想说咱们现在不如有很多那种又暴暖又透气的新型的衣服材质嘛。
她肯定会比老人穿的那种传统的什么纯棉汉衫要合适很多。
你包括可能还可以跌穿什么抓容的衣服来锁住温度。
我就想说我要按照现在这种更科学的思路来给我外婆整一个这个三明治穿法。
就省着她一会儿出汗一会儿发冷了。
结果我就发现说我这个想法有多美满，现实就有多骨感。
最后因为咱们厂店那种牌子，
她在版型和款式设计上是完完全全就不适合老年人的体型的。
那种专门给老人做的牌子就基本上还停留在上个世纪。
你就会觉得说这个新型的衣服材质和老年人的身体之间就仿佛有个结界。
就好像人老了你就只能凑合穿了一样。
这个事情发生之后我就一直在想，
我觉得养老看似是一个特别宏大的话题，
大家动不动就上上到什么地产，医疗质的也高度。
但很多时候它真的有特别具体特别细节。
像我外婆能不能穿上舒适合适的衣服，
这个其实就反映了这个养老行业的发展到底够不够精细吗？
说到养老行业的精细程度呢众所周知，
日本在老龄化这个事情上出发的太早了。
以至于他们已经发展出了一个非常成型，
并且还在不断进化的养老体系。
不过今天我们其实并不准备把这个话题聊得很大，
我们更想从衣食住行这四个最基本的生活化的角度，
来讲讲日本在这些方面都做了什么样的事情，
又面临着哪些困境。
日本老龄化这个词大家经常听到，
但是你可能不知道它到底有多严重。
按照联合国1956年颁布的老龄化判定标准，
这个日本早在经济高速增长期的1970年，
65岁以上人口就达到了7%，
正式不如了老龄化社会。
到了泡沫泼面后的1994年，
也就是24年后就突破了14%，
达到了深度老龄化的标准。
而在仅仅11年后的2005年，
日本65岁以上的老年人口，
比例迅速突破了20%，
就是摸到了老龄化的天花板，
也就是超级老龄化，
成为了全世界老龄化程度最严重的国家之一。
其实你想想看还挺吓人的，
日本进入最高等级的超级老龄化社会，
都也已经不知不觉是20多年前的事情了。
而且我不知道大家有没有意识到，
经常挂在嘴边团块世代，
当年人口规模超级龐大这一代，
他们其实目前已经全部都超过75岁了。
日本有一个所谓的2025问题，
指的就是从2025年起，
团块世代机体卖过的75岁大棺。
根据总务省发布的高零折统计数据，
截至2025年9月份，
全日本65岁以上的老人，
已经超过了3619万，
在总人口比例里面，
是高达29.4%，
也就是说，
每三个日本人里面，
就有一个是老人。
这个战笔已经毫无争议的，
就是排到全球守卫了。
听上去65岁，
像是一个划分老年的关键节点，
但其实在去年的人口统计里边，
日本100岁以上的老人，
连续55年刷新纪录，
已经有将近10万人。
就说按照女性更长寿的自然规律，
这里边女性战比达到了88%，
而最年长的老人已经114岁了。
所以65岁才人生过万呀，
正当年。
所以日本65岁以上的就业人数，
也连一年上涨，
就是目前已经超过了930万人，
占65家老人总数的25.7%，
也就是说在日本每四个老年人里边，
就有一位还在坚持工作。
而剩下的四分之三的老年人，
就只能靠领养老金来维持生活了。
如果是退休的公司支援，
每个月能领到15万到25万日币左右，
而对于自由职业者，
个体户和无业者的话，
就只能领到差不多7万日币，
按现在的汇率计算的话，
和人民币3千块不到。
所以说虽然老年人的战笔数字，
一直在激增，
老龄化给人的印象，
却是在衰减的。
包括他的社会地位，
分配到的社会资源，
以及群体的消费能力。
但其实通过总务省发布的。
2025家际统计报告，
我发现了一个很有意思的现象，
那就是在65岁以上的家庭里，
月之出光是满足基本温饱，
就已经捉金见肘了。
而教养娱乐的这个消费，
占比却超过了10%，
举一个具体点的例子，
65岁以上的单身没工作的老人，
平均每个月收入是3万日元左右，
其中12万都是养老金。
整个月的消费统计下来，
就只是吃饭、通讯、
水电煤这些最基本的，
赤字就已经高达3万日元了。
这里边还不包含高额的房租房贷，
以及医疗戒护费用，
可能总务省默认日本的老人。
都有房而且不会生病。
而在高额赤字的月消费清单里边，
有将近2万日元都花在了教养娱乐上，
也就是什么读书看展、
文体演出、
宝宝学习、
休闲旅游等等，
就是简单可以概括为一个月级的需求。
就属于老年人，
就即使每个月入不付出，
也不得不花的一笔硬性开销。
对，就随着老龄化的突围猛进呢，
消费市场虽然从年轻人主导，
逐渐往这个中老年方向去转，
但是其实从商家策来说，
很多对老年人的需求理解，
其实是非常片面和意想请愿的，
比如觉得老人日常花消少，
能花大钱的地方都是生命住院，
所以就把产品开发的重点都放在了医疗护理上，
再比如觉得市面上老人穿的衣服都长那样，
所谓的妈妈服就是暗红配大花，
那咱就继续生产类似的风格就好了，
就总体来说还是在延续市场惯性，
把老年人机械的理解成为一个遥远的特殊群体，
其实说句难听的就是不把人当人看嘛。
而从上面这组简单的消费数据，
其实也不难看出，
就是老年人跟每一个年龄阶段的人一样，
他也有取悦自己的需求，
也想从文艺娱乐里面收获情感价值，
从日常穿搭里面获得简单的开心和快乐，
所以在介绍功能性的借户用服饰之前，
我想花点时间，
先带大家看看在服装领域，
市老化这件事情是怎么普及到我们身边的。
其实日本市老化做的比较成功的服装品牌，
大众到人人介质，那他就是优衣裤。
那他的slogan呢，其实大家也都很熟悉了，
就是这个lifewear服饰人生，
主打面向所有年龄及性别的人群，
就是卖每一个人都需要的衣服，
从8岁到80岁都能穿。
所以当年轻的消费市场萎缩，
优衣裤跟很多品牌一样，
开始研究老年需求的时候，
他并没有像大部分品牌那样，
给老年服饰单独拎出来搞一个什么子品牌，
而是把这些功能需求大众化，
推广到每一个年龄段的人都能穿的衣服里边去。
那比如2020年的时候，
优衣裤推出了前开式的一系列的内大，
就是包括使用魔术贴的前开T恤，
按扣式的前开文胸和内裤等等，
就是让人更容易穿脱，
而这些产品的诞生全都源于一封信，
那写这封信的人并不是老人，
他是一位年轻的护士，
同时也是一名癌症患者，
他在平时针对老年人的护理工作里边，
尤其是在自己住院化疗和手术期间，
他切身体会到了原来每天穿的内衣，
一件套头是T恤，背扣是文胸，
甚至只是一条普通的内裤，
穿脱起来能让人精疲力解。
我这次手术完之后也是深有感触，
特别是手上挂着点滴，
身上揣着管子的时候，
想凭一几只衣服穿上一件内衣，
那简直是不可能的。
当这位护士在自己住院之前，
打算去选购一些前开式内衣的时候，
他发现全是护理用的款式，
就是想到治疗期间，
自己的内衣经常会被人看到，
他就完全跳不出来一件能穿得下去的。
那这时候他就想，
要是优衣裤能出这种前开式内衣就好了，
可以方便穿脱，
细致性好，也能塑干。
那现有的这个黑Tec加热保暖，
包括这个Alrhythm透气清凉系手，
都可以给它加进去。
那最重要的是，
能延续优衣裤舒适的检裁，
包括这个丰富的颜色选择。
那这位护士最后还开玩笑说，
即使以后握穿不起，
也好想穿上优衣裤的全开式内衣。
这个玩笑也太地狱了。
那2018年收到这封信之后，
优衣裤就开始听取更多患者，
包括护理师的需求，
着手开发前开式的这种内衣产品。
那考虑到病患的应用场景，
首先把颜色定位成，
能让心情变愉快的这种明亮的色彩。
尤其在医院这种地方，
好心情能让患者更快康复。
T序版形上，
会加大领口和袖口，
并且采用八分袖。
就是方便在医院扫描手环，
抽血打点滴。
衣服的后摆，
会设计得比前进更长一些，
符合老年人普通的腰取身形。
同时也增加活动空间，
防止走光。
然后前开的魔术贴，
采用亲夫的材质，
形状也会做成防刮伤的圆角。
同样为了不磨损皮肤，
通体都是无标签的设计，
然后把尺码、洗衣方法等这些信息，
全都印刷在衣服上。
面料上，
则延续优衣库擅长的这种功能性，
结合了不露出内衣痕迹的无痕设计，
包括ARISM透气苏干的特性等等。
另外也考虑到特定病患的需求，
比如为了让主线癌手术患者，
可以根据数后乳房的形态，
针对性的填入胸垫，
把胸垫的插口，
设计成了上下两层的分开结构，
让患者可以自由选择放胸垫的位置。
这种细节上的设计真是好贴心。
同时优衣库的开发人员，
也意识到了前开市内衣需求的普世性。
虽然从病患角度来看的话，
老年人占比剧多，
但其实对于刚出生的婴儿来说，
为了方便频繁的更换衣物，
它就有很多前开市的设计。
人长大了真的就不需要了吗？
毕竟人人都有可能面临检查，
住院或者被照料的时候，
方便穿脱属于每个人都会碰到的日常需求。
尤其人越老，就会越活回一个孩子样嘛。
使用的物品也会跟孩子的这个用品无限的接近。
所以这套前开市的系列内衣，
并没有打造成专门的借户或者老年产品，
而是推广到了女士、男士、儿童，所有的部门，
作为全性别全年零向产品，
上架到所有的连锁店。
这个系列因为穿脱的便利性，
以及诸多贴心的设计，
当然受到了病患、老年人，包括残障人士的欢迎。
同时也扩展到了社会上更多的群体。
比如说这个前开市的文凶，
对于哺乳期需要给孩子为奶的妈妈来说，
也是一个非常方便的选择。
像这种前开市设计方法，
确实是无论性别年龄，
就每个人都有可能用得到的。
就它其实没有限制，
但往往的就会被商家自我设限。
那其实优衣库有不少产品，
开发初中都是为了迎合老年人的需求。
比如我们熟悉的姚丽蓉，
包括青羽蓉系列，
都是为了解决高龄人群，
它既要保暖又怕太重的这种痛点。
可以帮助老人温暖过冬的同时，
还能避免医务过重带来的这种疲劳感。
尤其是无绣的姚丽蓉背心，
包括青羽蓉马甲，
就是堪称日本老人院的两大神器了。
老人穿着轻便暖和，
没有袖子、面料延展性强的特点，
也会方便护理人员给他们穿脱。
那你看看春晚小皮里边，
宋丹丹演的那个白云大妈，
标准穿搭也是青羽蓉马甲。
人家那穿搭可能是路途在梦风。
那你说这些产品，
就是真的只能老年人穿吗？
那显然不是。
姚丽蓉和青羽蓉，
就成了不同年龄的人过冬的首选。
所谓的老年人需求，
很多时候其实都是所有人共同的胡声。
而重点是，
优衣裤的这些产品，
在保证主流消费体验的同时，
也真正的去考虑和解决了。
老年人的功能性痛点。
这也是Lifewear打造。
无灵感服饰的一个核心理念了。
无灵感另一个重要的体现，
就是除去这些功能性产品，
优衣裤所有的衣服都削弱了。
某一个特定年龄段，
某一个特殊群体的喜好特征。
那通过中性的剪裁和低饱和的色系，
让老年人也能够轻松驾驭。
而且结合这个年龄所特有的这种淡染，
你能穿出来一种优雅的松弛感。
但是随着年龄的增长，
老年人逐渐被市场教会了妥协，
认为人老了，选择自然就少了，
人老了，就可以告别时尚了。
而为了扭转这种刻板印象，
重新建立老年人跟穿搭的这种连接，
优衣裤就开始在SNS上，
寻找这种高龄的代言人。
帮帮511,
就是他们家的一个重点KOL。
帮帮511是一对结婚38年的老年夫妇，
帮是丈夫，
帮是夫人。
511是两人的结婚纪念日。
他们因为日常非常注重情侣的穿搭，
退休之后就干脆开了一个印刺的账号，
把自己每天的OTD发上去。
每张照片真是可以说时尚又可爱，
那放俗图片在收到社里面，
大家也可以一块来感受一下。
而他们自己也没想到，
这些图片居然吸引了。
80多万人的关注，
其中就包括大批的老年粉丝。
他们用自己退休后的日常穿搭，
真切地告诉老年朋友们，
即使人老了，
也可以穿出自己的风格，
穿出活里满满的自信。
小红霜其实有很多带长辈去逛优衣库的地，
晒出来什么爸妈妈爷爷奶奶的松齿感穿搭，
确实会在那种刻板的中老年服装以外，
给到家人更丰富的选择。
咱这个节目真的是做得直，
我这个灵感说来就来了，
我决定从优衣库下手，
试试看到底能不能给我外婆买出点东西来。
很多人都觉得老年人玩不赚SNS，
但其实从那些铺天盖地的养生铁，
其实也不能看出，
他们的分享欲望比年轻人强烈的多。
就算不是分享到小红书，
也能通过微信群传播，
只要是真正击中他们的痛点，
口碑传播的力度完全不输网红流量。
同时因为老年人比起搜索，
更喜欢听别人推荐，
所以近些年直播平台的老年占比也直线上升。
其实想起来的话，
你会觉得这个方法更贴近线下购物的体验，
就很大成功的话不也就是依赖那种现场导购的推荐吗？
对，就是如果被成功重草并认可了这个产品质量的话，
老年群体的这个品牌粘性和复购的频率都会很高。
那其实直到现在，他们对电商也没有完全接纳，
毕竟看不见摸不着，还是不放心嘛。
那尤其如果网购的产品质量不过关，
会直接拉黑这个品牌，
甚至对平台产生不信任。
所以说并不是老了就好糊弄了，
到头来还是只有质量过硬的产品，
才能在这个市场真正存活下去。
那日本的电商为了让老年人更加放心购买，
也根据他们的购物习惯做出了很多调整。
比如原来主打年轻时尚集合店的ZoZoTang，
拓展老年客群的时候，
不开放线上会员的申请途径，
就让他们只能通过线下电来注册会员。
来到店里面，就能真实地感受到服装的板型、材质，
也能够利用店面特有的真人的陪伴式讲解，
打消老人网购的顾虑。
提高体验感的同时，也能增加品牌的信任度。
另外考虑到老人对自己的身材普遍不敏感，
就是网购的时候拿不准自己该买什么尺码。
ZoZoTang还专门开发了一款名为ZoZoSuit的身体扫描服装。
它是一件连体的紧身衣，
就是穿上之后，
它就可以通过全身的3D扫描，
再不上获得精准的尺码数据。
你说这个我也好想要，
你说有几个人能准确说出自己的腰尾吞尾。
这款产品因为迎合了大多数人的需求，
就迅速拓展到了全年零段，
甚至成功卖到了海外，
超强的伸缩性也深受大马欧美人的追捧。
同时为了兼顾不使用智能手机的客群，
让推荐不变的老人也能享受购物的乐趣，
有些品牌采用和老人院合作的方式，
把服装卖厂直接搬到了老人院的公共空间里，
铸打一个上门服务。
另外考虑到还有部分老人依然在用。
优购和电话预订的方式，
很多服装品牌会找对应年龄群的老年。
时尚杂志来合作，
让读者可以通过阅读杂志来种草，
直接下单订购新衣的服装。
以这本漫画真厉害，
这本推理小说真厉害，
等真厉害习品文明的宝岛社，
它旗下就拥有全日本最全面，
最细分的老年时尚杂志。
40岁，50岁，60岁，
每个世代都可以精准对应。
在这个纸梅不断衰弱的当下，
每一个世代的杂志都可以做到。
月销10万册衣裳，
而且这个销量在疫情之后。
还可以年年稳定上涨。
所以说这个现代纸梅的奇迹。
还是要靠远先那一代的读者来创造啊？
是，那比如针对60岁的这本杂志。
就是日本第一本，
也是唯一一本专门面向。
60岁以上高龄女性的时尚约刊，
名字叫做Stachina Anohido,。
帽斯也没有官方的中文一名，
我在这儿就姑且给它翻译成。
优雅的她。
在这本杂志创刊的2017年，
主编神夏镜子之所以把目标群体。
设定为当时的60家女性，
是考虑到她们的青年时期，
正好是70年代初，
安安和Nono等传奇女性杂志创刊的时候，
可以说是与时尚共同成长起来的一代。
她们认可时尚在日常中的价值，
即便到了60岁，
依然希望通过传达来表达。
个性和品味，
同时经历过经济高速增长期，
也让她们有着开放的消费观念，
除了满足基本温饱以外，
也愿意在娱乐和精神领域花钱，
愿意花钱去取悦自己。
而且年过60，不用辛苦工作，
不用操心家庭，
正是有钱有钱的黄金钱。
但是问题是，当时的市场上，
根本没有针对老年人的市场杂志，
所以优雅的她这本杂志推出之后，
就用年过60再次享受时尚，
就是这种急剧煽动力的slogan，
吸引了众多60家女性的抢购。
刚发行三天，就紧急再版，
第一本就卖超了5万册。
好笑的是，代表杂志人气爆棚的另外一项证明，
就是编辑部的电话响的固定。
在网络反馈已经非常普遍的2017年，
老年读者们看到杂志后，
有任何的感想或者问题，
第一反应还是先打电话。
比如有人问，
封面上这件衣服在哪可以买到？
也有人问，
这一页模特图的指甲油是什么牌子等等。
还有不着急的读者，
会非常复古的给编辑部寄明信票。
感觉整个编辑部就是梦回昭和年代。
是，编辑部也根据老年人喜欢线下分享的特点，
定期会举办读者的茶会，
收集60代老人的需求，
逐渐把最初的服装纸男进化成了一部汇聚服饰，
美容、旅行等丰富题材的老年生活方式杂志。
在这本杂志的封面上，
有一位让人过目难忘的老年模特，
他的名字叫做杰承安娜。
他近年刚刚步入70岁，
然后在优雅的他创刊以来的近10年里边，
他频繁地登上封面，
可以说是这本杂志的门面担当了。
那头银灰色的头发，
包括阳光的笑容，
就是让人只看到这个封面，
就能接受到满满的能量，
也是放长图在说弄嘴边给大家感受一下吧。
杰承安娜在十几岁的时候，
就作为模特出道了。
但是20出头，就结婚生子，
成为了全职主妇。
他的一辈子，大部分时间都奉献给了家庭。
直到过了60岁，
他才选择重新恢复模特，
包括演艺事业，
自己也开始写书，
创作插画。
所以他本人也是一个老年人在就业，
以及重新享受生活的这么一个立志榜样。
对，那所以杰承安娜作为高龄模特，
登上了杂志方面之后，
瞬间就成为了这个时代的一个。
对标形象。
那只是那一头银灰色的头发，
就解决了很多老年人，
关于染发的困扰。
那本来呢，他们就觉得，
频繁把这个白发染黑，
就是非常麻烦，而且不健康嘛。
而看到这个安娜的造型之后呢，
大家才发现，
就是即使保持自然的这种灰白发色，
也可以很时尚。
那杂志呢，也通过专题来讲解这个发色，
可以搭配的淡妆啊，
包括适合的服饰，
让老年人呢，
更能接受自己，
而不再畏惧年纪的增长。
那编辑部曾经收到过，
这样的读者反馈啊，
我本来因为重病住院，
心情沮丧，
但是读了这本杂志之后呢，
很想快点出院，
好好打扮自己。
那还有的说，
有好多杂志，
我连一半都读不完，
但是这本杂志，
我反复看了好多遍。
在人生想要放弃的时候，
遇到了这本杂志，
真的非常感谢，
感觉是上天赐给我的礼物。
那其实人整个的惊奇神，
跟自己的选择有很大关系，
就是如果你选择了妥协，
或者放弃，
没有了生活的热情，
不再享受日常，
那人的状态就是会一切千里。
那即便是年轻人，
你选择摆烂了，
那也一样可以变成形式走肉嘛。
那只是说老年人会在身体，
和大环境的双重影响下，
更容易产生这种负面的情绪。
而类似优雅了他这样的生活方式杂志呢，
就可以给到他们珍贵的勇气和自信，
能为他们后面的生活呢，
注入源不断的动力。
我觉得这也是，
就为什么老年人，
您肯入不敷出，
也要保证精神适量的原因嘛。
那说完世老话，
在大众层面的普及，
那我们再来看看，
针对病患，
以及需要照料的老人，
开发的专业介乎服，
在功能上呢，
都卷出了那些花样。
那其实从前面介绍的优异库产品里边，
就已经体现出了
老年介乎服的几个重要特征了。
那第一个呢，
就是要宽松，轻便，有弹性。
那宽松的版型呢，
可以满足老年人，
不想凸显身材的这种需求。
加大的袖口、领口，
也方便日常的检查和治疗。
当然最重要的是穿着的舒适感嘛，
就是可以大大降低，
衣物给身体带来的负担。
比如说裤腰上的这个送颈袋，
就采用了新型的橡胶材质，
它既不会脱落，
也不会勒出印子，
可以保证老年人顺畅的血液循环。
第二个呢，就是方便穿脱，
就是大量的采用这个。
刚才说的前开视觉构，
以及一扯就开的这个按扣啊，
包括魔术贴等等。
即使沿用了传统的扭扣，
扣子孔也是斜开的，
就是让老人单手也能轻松的。
寄上和解开。
而专门用于医院检查的衣服，
就更厉害了。
你记得那个固执服圣的漫画里边，
不是有个老奶奶说，
为了方便检查而选择穿和服吗？
对，那个奶奶特别可爱，
穿着和服，
然后手伸的肢脂都坐在一起。
对，那其实这个检查专用服呢，
就是一个和服的扬风改良，
它有点像两片大围巾搭载了一块，
你掀起第一片，
可以应对一些隔着单层衣物的这种检查，
比如听诊、CT，
而两片都掀开，
就可以做一些直接接触身体的检查了。
从穿脱的部位和场景上，
这个功能也在不断的去细分，
比如说从肩部穿脱，
从膝盖上穿脱，
还可以坐着穿脱，
也能躺在床上穿脱等等。
有些品牌甚至提供了改装咨询，
就是可以根据老人的需求，
定制一份服装改造清单，
由顾客自己决定，
采取什么样的改造方案。
这样一来，
你就不用扔掉自己喜欢的衣服了，
也能让它们变得更容易穿脱。
第三点就是耐脏、耐洗，
在保证舒适度的同时，
适度提高画线的含量，
让衣服即使粘上屋子，
也能迅速擦掉。
另外,
因为需要频繁清洗，
所以还得保证它不缩水不变形。
第四点，
可以粗略的用优衣裤的。
HITAC和ARISM来概括了，
就是保暖和清凉这样的功能性。
老人在不通细节对冷热会更加敏感，
所以要通过这些清编的内衣、
马甲等产品来控制体温。
当然，这种功能性不限于体温调节了。
专业介乎品牌KILAKU，
就有开发出一款
被评定为医疗气泄级别的价局服。
据说有恢复体能的功效。
就像这就是那种特别典型的。
日本的邪说黑科技。
它的原理是把身体发出的远红外线，
通过衣服的高浓度的。
这个陶瓷纤维，辐射回到身体上，
然后从而促进血液循环，
提高疲劳和虚弱状态下的这种恢复速度。
最后一点就是异军除异位了。
前面也提到了老人穿脱衣服的高难度，
尤其是对于长期臥床的老人来说，
就算做成方便穿脱的款式，
也得尽量降低更换的屏次。
所以衣服，尤其是内衣裤的材质，
得吸汗吸湿，
并且能长期抑制吸军资深，
以及异位的散发。
说到异位，
就是让我想起一个针对中老年群体的词汇，
那就是家灵臭。
就是说是上了年纪，就会散发的一种体臭。
我每次看到这一词都觉得心里很不适自卫。
这个名字最早是在1990年，
由资生堂研究中心发明的。
说在高灵者的体臭中，
检测出了一种名叫认膝权的成分。
简单来说，
就是身体表面的皮脂氧化，
而产生的一种物质。
据说会散发油垢和旧报纸，
混合出来的一种味道。
一般会在40岁之后的男性，
以及更年期之后的女性身上出现。
因为随着年龄的增长，
体臭会发生变化这个原因，
资生堂研究中心就把这种现象命名为家灵臭，
我们国内一般是翻译成老人味。
其实这个研究结果，
并没有得到世界范围内的认可，
欧美学家表示无法证明老人和任期权的明确关联，
而且每个人发出的气味成因复杂的很，
就是你跟你的饮食、烟酒、卫生等生活习惯都有着非常复杂的交产。
很难说40家的中老年人就一定会生产同一种物质，
并且散发出同一种气味。
尤其对于不能自理，
常年需要照顾的老年人来说，
这个味道就更加复杂了，
你很难用一个简单的老人味来形容。
也有专业的香水从业者指出，
人气权并不是什么害人的体臭，
而且经常被作为香水的成分。
比如说这个是Nel No.5里边就添加这块院家了。
甚至有人指出，
既然日本的中老年人能查出来这种成分，
那就是他们的饮食结构造成的，
那肯定是吃鱼吃多了。
这个轮站怎么最后就变成地图炮了？
对,
那我没有专业能力可以否定自身堂的研究成果，
但是从他们家配套生产的一系列加零臭臭产品来看，
这个研究成果确实有点促销用的嫌疑。
那近些年大家比较有印象的，
可能是他们家在2018年发明的压力臭这个词，
就是说人压力大的时候，
会散发出类似炒韭菜的这种刺激气味，
并推出了一系列对应的产品，
就是导致压力臭这个词在社交网络上也流行了一段时间。
那同样的，
加零臭这个词当年在刚进入新世纪的日本，
也开启了病毒式的传播，
甚至成为了中老年男性的一个代名词，
导致上了年纪的男性在家里边被老婆孩子嫌弃，
到了公司被年轻的下属嫌弃，
甚至在职场上出现了体臭骚扰这个说法，
就完全变成了一种年龄加性别的歧视，
是一种充满了日式霸凌色彩的这种歧视性话书。
那我对这个词比较敏感，
当然不光是因为我自己年过四世，
已经可以被划分为这个加零臭的群体了。
主要是想起家里的父母，
你包括祖父母，
就是并不觉得老人应该因为味道，
因为年龄的增长而被边缘化。
对，但这就确实也是日本社会另一种现实吧。
我突然想起了最近不有一词儿叫什么碳水链子，
就觉得哇，真的是恶毒到不行的营销属于。
所以就是从加零臭这个简单的词语上，
你就能看出日本老年人所处的这种舆论环境，
包括这个世老化在日本所经历的漫长的发展过程。
就是无论无灵化的服装，还是专业的戒护服，
虽然早就已经从单纯的方便护理，
全面进化成了这种功能性，包括尊严，包括时尚的结合。
但是整个社会对于老年群体的接纳，
显然不是一件衣服能够包裹的。
人心里边的世老化，还是有一条很长的路要走。
那说到功能和尊严的话，
接下来要聊的老年人饮食，
我这边正好也是有相关例子可供大家思考。
不过在展开饮食这块内容之前，
我还是想先引入一下日本老年化趋势下的人口结构问题，
因为接下来要讲的食和住跟这个人口的结构是息息相关的。
前面童谋哥已经分享过关于老年人口的数据，
大家都已经知道多吓人了。
那面对如此庞大的老年群体，
全部送去养老院，显然是不现实的。
就社会根本没有这种承担能力嘛。
所以居家养老，终究是绝大多数人的这个刚需。
但是问题又来了。
除了绝对直上这个年龄大之外，
超级老龄社会的致命问题其实在于他的家庭结构。
同样是根据推算，在2025年的时候，
日本有大约1840万户家庭的户主年龄是在65岁以上的。
其中有37%的户主因为没有子女，
子女不在身边，
终身未婚或说包括礼仪啊这各种原因嘛。
他们都是独居老人，
而即使是那种夫妇组成的家庭，
基本上两口子年纪，想想也知道大差不差嘛。
那这样的话就属于老人照顾老人的这种老老护理家庭。
那这个结果就意味着说你家庭内部的护理能力会不断下降，
最终就导致在家进行护理会变得十分的困难。
对，就是听起来不管家里有没有个伴都太难了。
对，好在因为人口数据是可以推测的，
你不至于说到了眼前了你才发现不对劲。
所以日本早在1997年就正式通过了戒护保险法，
并且从2000年开始正式实施。
戒护保险法翻译成中文，
应该叫做长期护理保险制度。
它的出发点就是把社会保险引入老年照料，
使得老年照料从过往的个人和家庭行为。
就转成一种社会保险式的互助行为。
在戒护保险法退出之前，
招呼老人这个概念主要指的是照料施能老人的日常生活。
但是戒护保险法的核心理念是，
支持和促进老年人实现自主生活。
翻译成大白话来讲就是，
戒护保险法想要实现的是，
通过为老人们提供各式各样的护理服务，
来尽可能满足绝大多数老人在家生活的需求。
我们可以从后申劳东省的资料上看到，
戒护保险法提供的戒护服务类别里面，
在家享用的服务就是其中非常大的一类。
我会在圣读层面贴张图，大家可以具体看一下。
有数据显示说，从这个法律实施，
一直到2.22年居家服务的使用人数增长了2.1倍，
而养老机构服务的使用人数仅增长了0.53倍。
这个也是非常核心合理的，
毕竟如果不是真的失去生活的自立能力，
想必绝大多数老人还是希望在家待着的。
但是年龄增长导致生活能力下降，
在生活中遇到各种不变，这也是很现实的一个问题。
相当于戒护保险法能够为老人们减少一些生活不变，
让他们能在家更舒服的生活，
同时也能为养老院减轻巨大的负担。
所以就眼看着这个超老林社会和居家养老成为大市所趋，
日本的食品企业们就开始吞着欲动了。
不过最初的时候，各个厂商的意识只是停留在说，
隐隐约约遇见到未来肯定会出现戒护食品这个赛道。
但是要用什么样的理念和什么样的标准来做出什么样的产品呢，
大家是没有概念的。
于是有个日本的协会就跳了出来，
主动牵头召开了制定相关行业标准研讨会。
这个协会呢，巧了，
正好就我们之前Q到过的那个日本罐头协会。
这么快就callback了。
在展开这个研讨会到底研讨了啥之前呢，
咱们先来快速的看一下老年人在饮食方面有哪些痛点。
一向2012年的调查显示，
在65岁以上的居家养老人世中，
有7成以上处于营养不良，
或者有营养不良风险的这个状态。
年纪大了胃口不好，吃不动，
那这个营养状况自然就跟着下降了。
对，但除了胃口不好，
这个自然规律之外呢，
该向调查里还有一半的老人是存在吞焰问题的，
就比方说你很容易误息了水，
误息了食物嘛。
根据日本亚克大学举古教授说法呢，
这个肺炎是日本的第三大死因，
而绝大多数老人患上肺炎的都是因为吃饭。
或者喝东西的时候不小心腔道，
就引发了物食性肺炎。
所以吞焰不便也是老人饮食的一大痛点。
除此以外，还有三成的老人在咀嚼程度上受到限制，
这个同样也很好理解，
你的肌肉或者牙口都退化，
都会带来这种拒绝伤的困难嘛。
那基于这些现实因素呢，
2000年10月,。
日本罐头协会就召集了5家相关企业来开研讨会。
大家最后一致认为说，
借户食品的开发不光要考虑安全卫生，
食品的功能性和物理形状也很重要。
就相当于说，
这一类食品既要能满足老人对营养的需求，
同时也要考虑到他们在吞焰和拒绝方面的问题。
在确定这个大方向之后，
研讨会决定以当时已经有的这个。
应用而食品自主标准作为基准。
那应用而食品分类呢，
是从断奶准备期到断奶完成期，
一共分为了五个阶段。
所以最初呢，
他们也设定了五个阶段的借户食品分级方案。
之后呢，
各有公司又根据各自的理念，
提出了不同的分类方案。
最夸张的一板是通过拒绝和吞焰形态的举证图，
提出了16种不同的分级。
这是做排列组合，做上演了吗？
好在,
最后这个研讨会呢，
还是决定将消费者异于理解放在首位。
最终就做出了一个分为四级的方案。
2002年,
这个研讨会正式变成了日本截户食品协议会。
该协议会呢，
首先就对所谓的截户食品做了一个定义，
截户食品的使用对象呢，
明确定以为设施能力下降的人群。
这个是因为后绅劳动审，
其实在94年的时候，
制定过关于老年人食品标签许可的处理规定，
但是当时呢，
那个规定的对象指向的就是，
患病者，
就受众很狭窄吗？
而加工食品行业想要推广的截户食品呢，
面向的是所有需要被护理的人。
除了核心的老年人之外呢，
你像那些可以独立进食，
但难以拒绝因务的广泛人群，
他们都可以成为截户食品的服务对象。
这个市场范围一下就变宽了？
除了拓宽使用对象的这个定义，
他们还非常注重用词上的人文关怀了。
在此之前呢，
有的商品会被叫做什么，
老年人专用食品，
或者引发食品。
就这些名字，
其实听彩会让人觉得有点不舒服嘛。
所以协会呢，
最终是采用了通用设计食品，
这个名称，简称叫做UDF。
那这个名字呢，
就把截户食品描述成了一种，
无论是否有障碍，
任何人都可以方便使用的东西。
那它既解决了名称上的心理负担，
同时也和截户食品想要实现的这个宽饭型就高度契合了。
相比之下，
这个发明出加零臭这种词的人，
都应该感到羞愧了吧。
那这个UDF呢，
它其实相当于是一套产品的认证系统，
就是它基于商品的硬度和粘度这两个物体维度，
把商品分为了四类，
第一类叫做容易拒绝，
第二类叫做用牙印可以压碎，
第三类呢是舌头可以压碎，
第四类叫做无需拒绝，
那各厂商就可以根据自家的这个商品的硬度和粘度数据，
来匹配这四种不同的等级，
并且呢去申请相应的标签来印在自己的商品上。
这样的话，
购物者就可以根据自己的拒绝能力和推验能力来判断，
说某一款商品适不适合自己使用。
为了让消费者能够更好地理解这四种分类区别，
协会在推广这套标签系统的时候呢，
还会用一些常见的食物来进行消费者教育，
比方说他们就会拿鸡蛋来举例，
那鱼子烧呢属于容易拒绝的类型，
茶碗蒸呢更接近无需拒绝，
所以那你要是能吃鱼子烧的话，
你就可以买那种贴着容易拒绝标签的介乎视频。
这个举例的方式太生动了，
一下子就变得通俗易懂了。
除了有明天协会牵头来制定产品标准之外，
2013年日本的农林水产审呢，
也对介乎视频的分类进行了一次梳理，
并且在2016年正式启动了一套三种颜色的视觉系统。
如果一个厂商的产品满足一定的硬性的营养指标，
比方说你的热量和蛋白纸能够达到某一种标准，
你就可以去申请农林水产审推出的蓝色标识。
一旦消费者看到产品上贴着这个标签呢，
就知道它属于营养补充类的视频，
是为那种需要额外补充营养的人群准备的。
而如果消费者看到一款产品上贴的是红色标识，
那它面向的呢就是那种有吞焰功能障碍的人群，
而如果你看到是黄色标识呢，
面向的就是有举决功能障碍的人群。
伴随着政策的标准的不断完善，
日本的各大视频企业终于可以开始他们最喜欢的大卷，
特卷环节了。
在这里我想有三家不同的企业作为例子，
来看看这个介乎视频这个行业到底可以有哪些卷法。
第一家企业大家都很熟啊，
其实就是那个麦莎江的那个丘比。
还记得前面我说那个罐头协会，
召开研讨会是找了五家企业嘛，
丘比呢其实就其中之一。
就是算得上是介乎视频行业的老人了。
对，就丘比这家公司其实你想一想还挺有意思的，
因为它从诞生之初就一直在拿日本人的健康作文章，
他们1925年推出蛋黄酱的时候呢，
为的是强壮日本人的体格。
伴随着老龄化的变迁，
这公司又开始变成了要强壮日本老人的体格了。
所以早在1998年，
丘比就推出了日本首款商用介乎视频，
并且从1996年起，
正式推出了这个翻译过来，
叫做温情菜单的介乎视频系列。
这有该系列名下，
目前一共是有五如四款不同的产品。
从产品形态上来看，
温情菜单卖的是那种袋装的技術视频，
但是呢主食，配菜，甜品都有，
各种选择言语俱全，
菜品在风味上也都是很经典的家常口味了。
什么鸡肉丸的蔬菜，
土豆炖肉，
青子冬，
牛肉,
手洗烧，
炖汉堡排，
什么雕鱼杂吹之类。
听着就足够传统，
是老人们会喜欢的这种熟悉的配方。
对,
不过这个整个系列的遵循的是。
前面所说的UDF的分类，
虽然它卖的是土豆炖肉，
但这个软烂的程度呢，
就已经炖到了像玉子烧一般的。
容易嚼碎的等级，
而所谓的青子冬和牛肉手洗烧呢，
它们在分类上被归为了。
牙银可压碎那一类，
就更接近风味粥的形态吧。
而前面所说的雕鱼杂吹，
它的特色在于说，
它的热量是普通粥的1.5倍，
并且还加入了145毫克的盖质。
而温情菜单的所有菜品呢，
都会采取那种低延分的方式，
但是会用高汤来提升风味，
就确保这些又软和又低延的东西，
它不光是健康的，可以吃得下去的，
同时也是美味的。
对，考虑算是很周到了。
在这个系列里面呢，
有一个是丘比家的王牌产品，
名字平平无奇，
叫做柔软的米饭，
是我感觉说，
我煮饭的时候多加点水就行了，
但是它不光用的不是一般的米，
人家用的是日本产的月光米，
整这么豪华？
对，同时呢，
它还通过2005年申请到的专利技术，
把软米饭做成了那种既不黏膩，
也不稀软的状态，
它不是那种湿搭搭一碗的状态，
而是说可以被捏成团的。
所以在官方的宣传里面呢，
还建议说可以用它来做创意料理，
比方说可以拿它捏什么葱花金枪鱼寿司，
或者可以拿来捏成圆形，
去代替红豆年糕汤里面那个年糕。
听着还挺合理的，
就是给老人们创造了可以吃到自己。
以前喜欢吃的食物的机会。
对，其实你不光是老人了，
年轻人如果你有时候有个什么？
身体不舒服呀，
或者牙疼、嗓子疼之类的，
如果你不想只是喝粥的话，
其实是完全可以买这种柔软的米饭来吃的。
那这就正好callback回了。
戒护食品的定义了，
就是面相的是需要被护理的人，
那这种需求从来都不只是到老了才会有的。
这也正好顺便可以提一嘴，
除了有推出专门的戒护食品系列之外呢，
就比自己的主业，
本身其实也算得上是老年人友好。
因为你想那种蛋黄酱、沙拉酱这种调料，
一方面是可以让干巴巴的食物变得更顺横。
另外呢，它的油脂、热量也比较高嘛。
所以在假设没有血脂问题的前提下，
其实这些高热量的酱在某种程度上，
也能帮助食量已经变小的人，
就觉得更少的情况下补弃基本的热量缺口。
就听起来是不是有一种丘比赢了又赢的感觉。
像丘比这样按照UDF的分类，
把家常菜窯们做成各种不同的软度，
这个基本是研发戒护食品的时候的一种基本方向了。
但是在怎么能做软这件事情呢，
每家真的是各有各的本事。
在这里呢，
我们要请出即时视频那期的主角之一，
这个大种治药。
这么快的返场了吗？
这是我自己也没有想到怎么又是它。
有种命中注定要给上次节目补课的感觉。
大家在上次节目中已经知道了，
大种治药非常喜欢在视频领域搞一些硬核的技术研发。
在戒护食品的产品研发上，
他们研究出了一种叫素军制进透法。
这个技术的前身是广道县利综合技术研究所。
视频工业技术中心在2002年是演发的一个冻结韩进法。
2002年是跟着那个UDF前后脚出现的吗？
对，就是当时这个技术中心呢，
就是说因为市面上已经开始出现了生品化的戒护食品，
但绝大多数都是糊状物，
包括你医院或护理机构里面呢，
基本上也都是搅拌机食物或者泥状食物嘛，
属于那种看起来就让人倒胃口的状态。
所以当时这个技术中心呢，
就选择用冷冻和解冻的方式，
让叫素能够快速的渗透进食材，
通过叫素来软化食物的内部细胞，
这样的话这个食物能够一方面保持原状，
就它的外观上不发生变化，
但同时呢，它里面的口感就已经变软了。
那这项技术到了大种治药那边呢，
就从冷冻解冻变成了使用他们家的看价本领，
AKA压力技术。
就他们家是选择用压力来把没种食材适合的叫素给渗透进去，
你像什么联藕这么硬的食材，
包括蔬菜肉类鱼类等，
都可以通过这项技术，
实现比普通食物的硬度去降低1%-1千分之一的软度。
我在收納嘴面放了一张图片，
大家就可以看到联藕牛肉和鲸鱼，
它的外观形态上完全没有变化，
但是用勺子轻轻一捏，
就变成了适合入口的泥状。
在这套技术加持之下，
因为对食材细胞的损伤比较少，
所以食物本身的营养素不会被破坏太多，
而它的风味，外观和色调也都是自然的，
就看起来和普通的餐食没有区别。
老人终于不用再吃虎祸了。
就我看一下他们菜单，
反正你从产品宣传图上来看的话，
真的跟正常的餐食是没有区别的，
什么核食、羊食、中华料理都有，
包括慢鱼饭、蛋包饭甚至乌冻面的，
你可以按照单品的菜摇来点，
也可以选搭配好的便当。
全部都是那种冷冻食品的形式，
微波炉加热就可以食用。
这么做的好处，
除了让老人可以吃得更自然，
更开心之外，
其实还有一个深层次的人文意义，
在于说老人们可以重新享受。
一起用餐的幸福感。
就大家是可以一起在餐桌上吃蛋包饭的吗？
而不是说老人就要被当作。
失去某种能力的人来被区别对待。
那至少在情绪观照层面。
是给足了这个情感价值的？
无论是秋笔还是大种，
他们的思路都是沿发出。
更软的食品，属于比较重的操作。
而有一家叫做Watami的。
日本联所餐饮品牌，
就很多人应该都见过，
就是它的汉字是写作和名，
其下有各种的剧酒屋和烧肉店，
还进入过中国市场。
这个Watami选的赛道是。
上门给老年人送餐，
Watami的送餐业务是通过。
他们收购了一家从1978年。
开始做食材套餐
宅配业务的公司来实现的，
这个公司是在2002年的时候。
就第一次尝试过
面向老年人配送晚餐便当，
又是2002年，
再次反映出2000年前后的时间点，
市面上真的是同时冒出了。
各种各样target老年人饮食的商业形态，
而到了10年后的2012年，
这家公司就已经被冰入了Watami集团，
并且对业务品牌进行了更新，
将专门面向老年人的便当宅配业务。
统称为Watami的宅食，
和丘比以及大众制药。
研发专门的介乎食品不同，
虽然Watami也提供超过30种。
符合UDF标准的那种软软的介乎食品，
但它的主力菜品其实就是正常的。
便当菜和熟食，每天新鲜配送。
听起来和点外卖差不多吗？
对，也看起来其实就是点外卖，
不过它其实是有几个值得注意的运营细节，
首先他们是完全预约制，
你需要提前订购，
就不像咱们现在中午饿了之后拿起手机现买，
完全预约制的好处就在于说。
公司层面可以有效的控制食材成本，
你订出去多少就做多少，
不会造成食材和资金上的浪费，
包括它所有的餐具也都是回收和循环利用的，
那这些素食都能尽可能的压低成本，
然后去降低这个菜品的定价。
另外的话，提前约制对于顾客的好处在于说，
你订的餐食可以更好地按照营养需求来进行规划，
比方说你订一个以五天为周期的套餐，
那瓦餐米这边就会根据均衡社区饮食的需求，
来给你把这个五天里的一日三餐都分配好，
不至于说让你每天都吃得很单调或者重复。
有时候碰上节日或换季，
还会融入很有季节感的当季食材或者节日气氛料理。
那这一点的话我个人非常感慨，
因为你别说老人了，
就每周我自己做饭的时候我都会很头疼，
就怎么能把菜品吃得又丰富又均衡。
你想咱其实尝吃的白肉红肉海鲜一共就那么几种，
你在想法是吧，他们太远了吧，
不能一股脑的只盯着一种吃。
考虑到我前面说过的，
日本的老人家庭主要是老人独具，
或者夫妇两个人年纪都很大了，
你每天要想着吃什么，
还要按营养需求来进行健康管理，
这个真的太消耗经历了。
而且老人吃的也不多，
你又要买很多家里常用调味料，
可能放着放着就过期了。
我记得上次节目播出后，
就有听有留言说，
父母已经七十多了，
对做饭这件事情很头痛，
阿姨请不到满意的，
自己做的又很累，
你仔细想想的话，
真是一个很现实的困局。
毕竟就算学会了点外卖，
但是外卖普遍的高油高盐高糖，
对他们的健康状况而言，
也是一个非常大的负担。
对，所以这些Watami这种，
从食材种类，
营养搭配合盐分管理等，
角度全面入手，
为老人们去专门定制，
适合他们的便当菜品，
真的是非常合理的。
根据Watami官网给出的宣传，
他们号称自己在
病患高龄者送餐市场中的这个份额，
从2010年到2024年，
连续15年都是消灌，
这也值得成为消灌。
而且他这种服务，
同样也是有深层词异的，
因为是每天都会有人去当面，
配送到老人手中，
间接起到了定期确认。
老人身体状况的作用，
所以这种服务，
本身还可以被视为说，
社会系统的一部分了。
我现在这个印象还挺留在。
和民室拒绞屋这些事情上，
我还是没有完全扭转过来，
他在背后还做了这些事情。
你像类似于Watami这样的。
给老年人送餐的服务呢，
在日本其实是一个很热门的赛道，
我在网上看了一些评测，
真的是给我看的眼花缭乱，
但是我觉得说，
可预见的是这个赛道，
绝对是今后中国的热门战场。
各位就等好吧。
那讲完了老年人可以吃点啥，
还有一个细节是我想补充的，
就是老年人拿什么餐具来吃。
你前面说过了，
人上的年纪即使没有罹患重大的疾病，
你的身体积也会自然而然的老化。
首先可能反映在你的食欲上，
而食欲下降导致营养流失，
营养流失导致肌肉下降，
手上的劲可能就越来越小了，
手也可能开始多做了。
如果在叠加上一些基础疾病，
可能还会出现手部麻痹的情况，
那这些问题反过来，
可能就又会导致老人，
这个进食就变得更加困难，
因为你会拿不稳，
送不到嘴边，
季儿就会导致你吃得更少。
这真是一个令人绝望的四寻环。
对，那针对这个问题，
日本市面上是有大量的。
专门为老年人设计的戒护餐具，
我在这里挑了几种。
临床上常用的餐具类型，
来和大家分享一下。
比方说在筷子方面，
有一种看上去，
我觉得特别像个佳大号的孽子，
你只要把手指搭上去，
就可以稳稳地拿住它，
而且你用很小的力气，
就可以把食物夹起来。
这种款呢，
主要是针对手指僵硬，
或者说手指力气变小的人，
然后因为它的款式是分左右手的，
所以假如一个人需要去用。
自己不习惯的另一只手来夹菜的话，
你比方说手腕扭伤了，
右手用不了了，
只能用左手吃饭，
那是可以通过用这种。
借户用的筷子来轻松实现的。
这个使用场景其实还挺刚续的，
就是朴实性非常强。
我感觉值得被美加美护。
放进这什么印记物品清单里面。
除了筷子呢，
还有一种借户用的勺子，
它的勺柄是软的，
可以自由弯曲，
所以这样的话，
你就可以根据自己需要的角度，
来控制好这个勺子的头，
让食物能够更容易。
踏进这个勺子里，
然后送到口中，
而且还有那个手柄的部分，
还做了加粗设计，
十分便于抓握。
还有一种掌心套袋也很有意思，
它作用原理特别简单，
其实就是让你把勺子或。
插子套在你的手上，
这样的话，就算是你的手指。
完全无法用力，
或者无法抓握，
就只要你还能转动手腕，
就可以利用这个套袋来。
稳定你的进食。
借户用的盘子和碗，
那就更好理解了，
你的外侧，
底部肯定需要能防滑，
内侧需要有一定的倾斜度，
这样的话，
老人就可以更好地把盘子里的食物。
吃干净。
而那种传统的日式汤碗，
很多都会额外加装宽大的手柄，
老人在喝汤的时候，
就可以直接握住那个把手，
从而非常平稳，
安全的端起汤碗，
就不会洒出来，
也不会被烫着。
除了这些成规餐具之外，
我还搜到一些特别好玩的小物件，
比方说，
有一种是可以装在。
纸盒牛奶上的手柄，
就是它可以让你
在倒牛奶的时候，
更容易控制好。
就是帮助老人少花一点力气。
还有一种开瓶器，
是能够帮你快速拧开。
三种不同的瓶盖，
讲道理，
我看了都觉得心动啊。
还有一种是那种
带吸嘴的软瓶子，
就看着跟奶瓶的结构很像，
但它那瓶身是软的，
轻轻一按，
就可以流出那种流质的食物。
以上Q到参举，
大家可以搭配着来看。
其实无论是戒护视频，
还是戒护参举，
说到底所有产品出发店，
都是为了尽可能的。
支持老年人去恢复。
正常的饮食节奏。
无论是从健康上，
还是心理上，
都是有重大意义的。
聊完了老人在家吃饭的问题之后，
咱们紧接着可以再看看。
老年人能够怎样
安全舒心地住在自己的家里。
前面莎拉也提到了，
大部分日本老年人都是居家养老，
所以在住这件事情上，
日本政府早在正式进入。
老龄化社会之前，
就开始筹备相关政策了。
1963年的老人福利法，
首次将养老，
纳入了社会体系。
政府不仅开始关注住宅内部的。
是老化改造，
包括地面防滑，
增设扶手等这些基础安全，
还对居住区的外部环境。
进行了全面的改善，
包括设置颇道，
改善楼梯间，
增设人形通道等公共设施优化，
增加空地上的绿化面积，
包括小型休息设施等等。
到了1995年，
建设省发布了应对。
长寿社会的住宅设计指南，
开启了日本沿用
几十年的世老化设计标准，
从生活空间的集中设计，
到安全保障测试，
设施的世老化等等，
都提出了非常具体的应对方案。
而真正让自立居家养老。
变成可能的，
还是前面提到的，
在2000年实行的戒护保险法，
除了可以享受上门。
护理服务之外，
还可以申请
世老化的居家改造，
最高可以获得
20万日元的补助。
在世老化改造这一趴。
要拿来举例的品牌，
同样非常耳熟能详了，
那就是日本电器界的。
欧记松下。
早在1990年，
松下就开始
研究老年群体的需求，
并着手开发，
支撑高龄化社会的。
通用设计。
到现在旗下已经有。
四家子公司，
覆盖了从世老化电器，
辅助器具，
护理服务，
到养老住宅的各个领域。
那整个养老项目，
命名为H3，
他的理念就是，
无论多大年纪，
都能做自己想做的事。
那咱就先从他们家的。
看家本领来看看吧，
就是松下是怎么把世老化。
融合进家用电器的，
那电话坐机这个东西，
在中国的家庭里边。
几乎消失了，
但是在日本，
仍然有大量的老人在使用，
那松下在自家生产的。
这个坐机里边，
除了电话零声，
还加入了语音提醒，
这个零声和语音，
会交替播放，
然后同时，
电话还有一个闪烁，
发出光芒，
就是确保听力不好的老人，
也能觉察到。
那对于高风险的迷惑电话，
也会在接起之前，
进行语音提醒，
说这通电话很可疑，
请谨慎接听，
就是无论接不接听，
都会自动录下通话的内容，
方便家人，
或者护理人员，
去判断老人，
有没有受到诈骗，
那关键时刻，
也能成为报警的一个证据，
真是个房电站，想能守啊。
那另外，
考虑到老年人对家里，
温度和湿度的变化不太敏感，
就是为了防止这种变化，
带来的重鼠等突发状况，
松下就在电话里边，
还设置了温度和湿度的传感器，
如果到达了这个警戒职，
会通过语音和接经评的颜色，
来提醒老人注意。
那再就是结合导国，
灾害频发的这种特性，
这个电话里边，
也设置了安心的报警系统，
根据提前设置好的邮政编码，
来触发提醒，
像什么地震啊，台风啊，
这种自然灾害，
还有什么电车事故啊，
敲两垮他这样的，
公共设施故障等等，
都会通过语音和接经评，
来提示警戒和避险信息。
那根据通知的这个紧急程度，
音量和亮度也会相应发生变化，
那当然像温度湿度的监测啊，
包括这个灾难事故的提醒等功能，
也不是坐机电话的专利了，
松下的电子摄像头啊，
什么监控门铃啊，
等很多家用电器都有集成。
那为了让老人也能在家做做基本的清洁，
松下还设计出了一款超轻的手持吸尘器，
那从部件啊到材质全面减重，
整个这个重量不到两千克，
让老年人也能轻松握持。
另外这个吸嘴处呢，
还设置了传感器，
就如果遇到了不易发现的垃圾或者灰尘，
会闪烁红色的光芒来提醒，
这个吸嘴的前边呢，
还会启动这个LED灯进行照明，
而像空调啊马桶啊抽烟机，
等这些清理起来比较费劲的这个电子产品呢，
全都加装了自动清洁功能，
就是每次使用完就会启动一次清洁，
就是避免时间久了之后就会变得过脏，
一方面容易损坏，
也会增加这个老人的清理负担。
那以上这些属于在日常家电中加入的适老化功能，
而在专业的介乎领域，
松下也利用先进的技术，
开发出了从监测，
护理到康复的丰富的产品，
那比如一款测试老年人身体能力的坚定系统，
就是通过身上的感应绑带和外部的障碍设备，
可以模拟出身体的负担承受能力，
并且把它数字可视化，
就是方便护理人员对老人去采取相应的一个介乎措施。
而在护理方面呢，
松下也未常用的护理床，
增加了各种实用的电子功能，
那首先是通过按钮，
可以让老人自己调节这个床脉的高度，
且把这个调节范围分成多段，
可以分别调整背部、腿部的这种弯曲度，
方便帮助老人起身和躺下。
床垫内的气压，
还可以根据人体重力自动调节分散压力，
避免躺久了之后会产生入床的问题。
那高端的产品线里边，
还能从床上直接分离出一部分，
自动折叠成座椅，
这样就完全不用老人自己上下床了。
太靠近了。
那松下在自己家开发的老人院，
包括老年公寓里边，
还装入了全屋智能康养系统。
就是像睡觉前后自动拉窗帘，
调整灯光亮度什么的。
但这个在国内的全屋智能案例里边，
已经不算傻了。
重点是为了能分析和调整老人的睡眠状况，
房间里边加装了多个传感器，
对心率、呼吸、睡姿等等进行监控。
同时根据室内条件和身体状态，
随时调整温度、湿度，
包括氧气的含量，
从而提供一个舒适的睡眠环境，
达到深睡住眠，浅睡住养的一个目的。
但每天商场的这个睡眠报告，
也方便医护人员去长期监测老人的健康状况，
给出对应的护理和医疗方案。
还有一款传感器可以感知地面的微震动，
即使监测到意外的发生，
就是万一老人摔下床或者企业跌倒什么的，
这个传感器会迅速通知护理人员，
把等待救援的时间可以缩短到五分钟以内。
这个功能真的很实用，但听上去觉得好贵啊。
对，确实。
说到养老摄事，
松夏也同步在90年代就开始入局了，
搭配自己家先进的这些电子设备，
就开发出了高端的老人院，老年公寓等抗养项目。
虽然说每家都是挤破头，
这个报名也是半年以后才能入住的火热程度，
但是费用确实也不便宜，
每个月基本在20万到50万日元这样的区间了。
而且入住的时候，还得额外再缴拿一笔御付金。
不知道大家还记不记得，
就是前面提到的日本养老年金的额度，
退休职员每个月也就能领到15到25万，
自由无业的只有7万左右，
所以这些高端摄事并不是一般人能住得起的。
能看到的人数在整个老龄化的池子里边也是微乎其微的。
松夏也是意识到了这一点，
所以开始逐步向下兼容，
在全国各地的社区搭建起自己的居家护理中心，
提供通勤、上门、入住等丰富的这种护理选择。
同时也可以根据每家每户的实际状况，
给出针对性的住宅改造方案。
当然这个自己家的市老化改造可不是你想改哪儿就改，
想要走借户保险流程的话，
更得等这个专人来认定。
松夏也培养出了一批专业的居住环境规划师，
同时具备护理和建筑的双重资格，
他们会根据老人的身体状况，
以及家里的实际条件来选择合适的改造方案。
为了不要过分影响老人的日常生活，
也会尽量降低施工的含量。
可能有人觉得市老化改造这个词听着挺大，
但不就是装点扶手，我自己动动手也能搞定啊。
首先居家的市老化肯定不是装个扶手这么简单，
而且单说一个扶手里面的学问，
它确实也不简单。
也是因为这回住院，尤其在刚刚手术完那几天，
我切身体规到了扶手的重要性。
就是不用说下床了，没有扶手我坐都坐不起来。
听着都好疼啊。
但也不是随便一个扶手都能让我坐起来。
就这个扶手的位置，角度和材质其实都挺重要的。
那如果把这些点都选对了，能适办公备，
那选不对这个效果真的是天差地别。
所以现场的勘查测量，
就是规划师前期的一个重要的工作。
那到底哪该装，装几个，
都是规划师需要考量的范围。
为了真正帮助到老人完成日常的一些行动呢，
而不是成为扎眼的阻碍，
那规划师也会尽量利用相近的色系，
把扶手隐藏在柜体啊，台面，
包括这个墙面上，
让老人在不自觉的前提下享受到这些便利。
那同时呢，还能减少扶手，
在衰老这件事情上产生的心理暗示。
对，不然你想想就满屋子都是扶手，想得都闹心。
那离里外外的房间门呢，也是重点的改造对象了。
推拉门呢，一般是改造的首选。
相比平开门呢，可以在开关门的时候少占用一些空间，
也能方便使用轮椅的老年人进出。
而且对于肌肉力量减退的老年人来说，
推拉门呢，也更容易开合。
那一些不涉及隐私，
而且经常需要出入的房间，
甚至就可以直接把门拆掉了嘛，
就是改造成一个开阔的通道。
那同时为了防止老人半岛啊，
以及使用轮椅，
全屋的通道呢，要尽可能消出高度差这件事情。
就是要抹平所有的门槛啊，台阶等等。
就是不方便处理的，也可以加设这个踏板或者颇道。
在整个家里边要做到无障碍通信。
那出房卫生间的台面高度呢，
也要根据老人的操作习惯来调整。
如果使用轮椅的话，
还得把除柜下方的空间往里收缩，
就腾出轮椅能进出的一个空间，
方便轮椅上的老人接触台面。
就这么简单举例，
就感觉到说要改造的细节真的还是挺多的。
这还没完呢。
那世老化改造的重中之重呢，就是浴缸了。
那大家也知道日本人有多热爱泡澡，
家家都装着浴缸。
但是对老年人来说呢，
泡澡这件事就变得非常高危。
就是浴室的这个磁砖地面啊，
包括浴缸的这个亚克力材质，
本来就很滑。
那进出浴缸的高度差，
也很容易让这个老人半岛。
所以要改造的话，
首先是浴室的这个墙面和地板，
可以把原来又滑又凉的这些磁砖呢，
更换或者加盖一层这个放花垫。
像龟枣泥这样质地粗糙能增加阻力，
触感柔软又温和的材质呢，
在浴室的改造中就非常受欢迎。
那浴缸的话呢，进出助力的地方，
需要加设扶手。
外侧的地上需要增加垫板。
浴缸里面呢，
也可以放一个小型的座椅，
减少高度差，
方便老人进出。
进入浴缸之后呢，
你就可以直接坐在这个小椅子上，
这样蹲起都更省力一些。
当然了，钱包允许的话呀，
也可以买一个松下的坐式淋浴器。
左右两侧的多个喷水孔呢，
能制造出丰富的水雾，
包裹全身。
不用泡在水里边，
也能享受到泡澡的感觉。
同时呢，
还可以大大降低泡澡，
对老人的身体消耗。
这玩意听下都觉得好爽啊，
就差咱钱了。
那目前松下在全日本呢，
已经拥有66处老人院，
包括老年公寓，
184个护理服务点，
和看护中心，
已经累计完成了
近三万件的居家改造。
同时还开发了
数千个世老化，
以及护理专用的产品，
通过遍布全国的
124家店铺进行销售。
那比起这些听起来，
很宏大的规模，
松下更让我触动的呢，
其实是一些细节上的优化。
那比如说在刮户刀片，
包括这个电池的产品上，
把里边的具体数量，
用大大的数字印在这个包装上，
就是方便老年人呢，
可以快速选购嘛。
那再比如，
在他们这个H-Free的项目网站上，
你会看到一个非常清晰的专题页，
就无论你是老人本人，
老人的子女，
还是老人的护理人员，
都可以在这儿学习到。
戒护的入门解决方案，
包括怎么申请这个戒护保险，
怎么选择戒护方式和用品，
怎么在家里进行世老化改造等等，
就是介绍的非常强劲，
而且简单意图。
收到随便放个链接给大家做个参考吧。
我觉得这种人心化的，
就很细节上的贴心，
才是世老化真正需要的。
除了可以在养老设施，
或者自己家享受看护服务，
后上劳动社还在推进居住医疗，
护理，预防护理，
生活支援等一体化服务的。
社区综合护理体系。
那这儿针对的不一定是。
严重的生理疾病，
就是如果你只是对孤独，
或者病痛感到不安，
也可以利用这个系统来进行咨询。
那工艺设施以外，
政府也在鼓励，
盈利性的企业和民间机构，
都加入进来，
争取实现30分钟养老服务圈，
形成24小时的享用网络。
比如现在很多连锁便利店，
也开始承担部分社区的。
这个养老服务功能。
毕竟随处可见的便利店，
是老人们最容易触达的地方。
部分店面会整合送餐送药，
代表费用，
然后包括健康咨询的各种服务。
比如711就有跟日本各个地方政府，
签订一个守护协定，
在部分店铺会开展安全战活动。
店员一旦发现附近有疑似走失的老人，
就会联系警察，
还会帮助阻止老年人在店铺的ATM机上，
被电炸汇款等等。
这个以居住点为核心，
由多个社会机构，
携手构建的伏地系统，
连同戒护保险，
养老设施，
是老化改造一起，
就支撑了一张应对超级老龄化的大网。
那最后就再让沙拉带大家去看看，
在衣食住行的最后一趴，
还有什么应对老龄化的措施。
那聊完了老人们的居家生活，
最后我们再来看一下他们在出行方面的需求和问题。
根据内阁府关于老年人的住宅与生活环境调查，
60岁以上老年人的外出频率总体上市已，
大多数几乎每天外出为主了，
这个人群比例大约占6成，
其次就是每周两到三天，
以及每周四到五天这么一个顺序，
那这个数据是不停下来，
感觉还挺乐观的。
但是随着年龄增长，
几乎每天外出的人群比例就开始逐渐下降，
到了80岁之后，
这个数据就会跌到低于一半。
另外，有专家认为，
有一到两成的老年人属于闭门不出的状态，
根据后身劳动审的定义，
外出频次如果每周低于一次的话，
就会被归为闭门不出，
而闭门不出会成为导致长期臥床，
或者需要戒护的原因之一。
就这句话这一听还挺奇怪的，
因为按理说，
你不出门可能是因为健康有问题，
怎么反而就成了说，
不出门会导致健康产生问题，
所以咱们还是得先看一下，
出门和健康之间的关系。
首先最容易理解就是人只要缺乏运动，
就会导致肌肉和体力逐渐下降，
如果你外出频率减少，
就很直观的意味说你走路会少，
你走路上就会导致腿部肌肉下降，
身体平衡也会随之降低，
于是人可能就会越来越觉得说，
出门很可怕，
因为会担心出门摔倒，
肌耳就会导致更加减少外出。
前面说到这种轻点的恶性循环又来了，
这个国土交通省的一个报告显示，
在75岁以上的人群中有17%的人，
这个连续步行上线是100米以内，
就觉得听起来还挺难过的。
我之前在一个博客里也看到一句特别现实的话，
说的是老人总说待在家里舒服，
究竟是因为在家更轻松，
所以待在家里，
还是因为出门太辛苦，
所以待在家里。
现在太扎心了。
出门的好处处的能够保持这个基本的身体机能之外，
它最重要的一点是对你的大脑进行刺激，
因为你在外出的时候会接收到各种的信息，
你会看到不同的景色，
过满路的时候你需要判断交通状况，
买东西的时候你要选商品，算价格，
还有跟店员交谈，
包括你可能还碰见邻居，
你们聊上解决。
这些活动都会雕用到大脑的不同部位，
算得上是一种脑力上的锻炼。
如果一个人同时缺乏体力和大脑上的锻炼，
那就会很容易衰退到需要戒护的状态。
所以就前面说的这个戒护保险制度呢，
他们非常鼓励老人去租借各种帮助出行的物品，
比方说什么辅助的拐杖，
无障碍的斜坡，轮椅，不嫌弃，
就这些东西都可以用保险来租借，
而且费用超级低，
就你只需要用市场家的医折，
就可以租到这种东西，
比方说你在市场上面租一个轮椅，
它的月租是2020日元，
那用了戒护保险的话，
每个月就只需要202日元了。
几乎就是白菜价了吗？
对，你从公共财政之初的角度来看的话，
早期介入早期预防，
尽可能延缓老年人在生理和认知层面的衰退，
你这么做的成本肯定是远低于你去照顾一堆。
因为没有及时介入，
而彻底需要中毒护理的老人的。
除了这种步行范围内的出行之外，
那自己驾驶汽车，
或者乘坐公共交通也是很重要的一种出行方式了。
去年SP里面，
我曾经推荐过一部日剧，
叫做赵紫月留医，
里面有一段剧情讲的是女主说，
自己这次公路旅行之后，
就准备归换驾照了。
当时我还没太get她说这个是啥，
这回查了一下，
原来是日本，
它是有一个专门的自愿交换驾驶证的制度的。
2006年的时候，
商交量是2.1万件，
到了2019年的时候，
这个数字就上升到了60万件。
为了推进老年人交换驾照，
不同地区的自治体，
还会有准备各种优惠措施。
你比方说东京都就会提供那种。
什么患者转送服务，
七折券，
出租车九折券，
大版府还有电动代步车，
购买折扣券。
就是想尽办法让老人家不要再开车了。
你为了保障这个驾驶安全，
让老年人尽可能采用公共交通，
这个在逻辑上很好理解嘛。
毕竟和日本整体上，
这个非常低的交通事故死亡率相比，
老年驾驶者引发的死亡事故率，
算得上是触目惊心。
而且大家去日本玩的话，
你多少也能感受到日本在。
无障碍设施方面，
做的已经算是比较全面的了。
过渡交通审在2024年的时候，
公布了一个公共交通工具无障碍化的成绩。
在旅客设施，
比方说车站、公交站之类的地方，
台阶的消除率在2.23年末，
已经达到了94%。
无障碍厕所的设置率是92.3%，
飞机的无障碍率，
更是已经实现了100%。
除了推动公共交通无障碍化的法规之外，
日本在道路交通安全法上，
也对老年代步车的尺寸，
动力，还有形式的道路都做了明确的规范。
各大车辑和技术产业，
对于老年代步车，
包括无障碍的汽车，
更是做了各种各样的技术研究，
就花伙很多。
但是在我们乐观的聊完一时住之后，
在出行这个问题上，
我决定采取破冷水的态度了。
因为无论车进门，
他们的技术做得有多好，多厉害，
这些领先的东西，
终究只是浮于少数群体的。
对于绝大多数的日本国民而言，
他们所面临的出行难题，
其实是一个更宏大，更为结构化的困局。
在这里我想用一个叫做。
购物弱者的社会现象，
来展示一下在日本这个社会环境里面，
出行问题和社会的老年华程度，
这两者之间究竟构成了一种什么样的死循环。
2017年，日本总务省针对这个购物弱者这个现象，
出过一个209页的调查报告书，
报告中引用了农林税产审对于购物弱者的定义，
所谓的这个购物弱者，
指的是以老年人为主体，
在购买食品或者餐饮方面感到不便，
或者困难的人群。
根据数据推测，
截至2010年，
居住地距离生鲜食品，
销售店铺的直线距离在500米以上，
且未拥有汽车的人口约为850万人，
其中65岁以上的人口，
是其中的380万人。
这个数字还只是2010年的统计，
放到现在怕会增加得更吓人了。
购物弱者这个现象，
最初是发生在农村地区，
由于人口流失，本地小店相机倒闭。
以前的话，
大家还可以开车去大一点的地方采购，
但你上了年底之后，
你把这个价值一归还，
生活就彻底陷入了不方便的状态。
虽然前面也说了，
为了鼓励大家返还价照，
地方自治体会有各种鼓励你去。
达成公共交通优惠措施。
而且这个公共交通的无障碍化，
不如从数据上看起来，
做也还可以嘛，对吧。
但问题在于，
人口下降导致的不光是店铺倒闭，
这个公交车的运送人数，
同样也是大幅下滑的呀。
是，环环相扣呀。
根据国土交通省的统计，
日本全国有60%的运输运营商，
都是处于亏损状态的，
尤其是地方巴适的收支笔，
就更是处于极低的水平。
在2007年的2016年这10年之间，
民间运营的定期公交线路，
就1.4万公里被废除。
而且就算你没有返还价照，
你还能开车。
但是由于需求减少，
包括经营者后级无人的情况，
地方上的加油站数量，
同样也是在持续减少的。
大家是不是觉得，
听起来越来越绝望？
就感觉再也好不起来了。
别急，因为更绝望的还在后面。
就前面说的主要是，
这个农村，
或者地方小城市的情况嘛，
可是很快呢，
这个问题就蔓延到了都市郊外的住宅区，
也就是所谓的团地。
大家在之前那个讲，
团地的建设剧里面也都看到了，
这个团地居民的老领化程度是非常可怕的。
而且因为这些房子呢，
主要都是70年代那会儿开发的，
当时还不太有无障碍设施的概念，
很多楼房呢，连电梯都没有安装，
一个老年人上楼下楼就已经够费劲了。
而团地呢，
原先也都是在500米的步行圈内，
配备了以超市为核心的各种零售啊，
餐饮啊，
没用美发店，
但是你伴随着人口的流失，
还有大型零售店抢走生意，
团地配备的小商店们也在不断的倒闭，
导致那些还居住在团地的老人们，
买东西就会越来越困难。
那这么说起来的话，
是不是生活在大城市里就没有问题了呢？
现在我都稍微抢答了，肯定不是。
对，你即使是生活在大城市里的老人们，
他们原本住在你表说车站前，
或者商店街步行圈的这个范围里面，
生活是很方便的。
但大家都知道嘛，
城市里的商店街是在急速衰落的，
前面数据呢也提到过说，
很多老人最多也就能连续走过100米，
那你让他们离开以前赖以生存的商店街，
走去更远的地方购物，
从体义上面来讲真的是不现实了。
我之前读了一篇相关论文，
里面在抛弃完购物弱者的各种困境之后呢，
也分享了一些目前正在记忆尝试的先运对策。
比方说上门配送，
或者定期派免费班车来接送，
包括还有企业，
专门做的是那种开着小卡车来进行移动贩卖的生意，
就有点让人感到哭笑不得的是，
这种移动超市的模式其实在五六十年代特别流行，
最初是个体经者和中小型超市会这么做，
后来很多大超市也加入了这个浪潮，
是一直到四加吹普及大型购物中心扩张这个模式，
才逐渐退出那个大家的事业的。
历史真的就是一个轮回，
没想到十个几十年后，
会以这样的原因重新登场了。
然后target还是同一波人，是吧？
在这篇论文里，作者原话是这么说的，
说可以看出以移动贩卖为中心，
各地正在开展各式各样的尝试，
尽管存在因为人手不足而不得不中止的项目，
让人感到现实厌倦。
但利用自动驾驶，无人机等新技术，
弥补人手不足的探索也在进行中。
虽然最后有个转折，
但整句话听下来只会觉得更绝望。
所以其实你无论推出什么样的对策，
不管你是上门配送还是开班车，
还是什么开卡车巡回售卖，
你背后的核心要素都是人，
而日本社会最大问题，
又在于说人在变得越来越少。
所以我觉得购物弱者这个问题，
是可以很好的反映出，
日本在目前的人口结构之下，
所有的难题都是如何缓缓相扣的。
但是每个社会问题都是不一样的，
我觉得对于咱们老了而言，
你至少网购这种事情，
肯定不会成为痛点嘛。
包括配送的问题，
我相信很快就可以通过无人驾驶和AI技术实现。
包括之前我还看过，
现在已经有那种可以当护工的机器人，
帮你翻个身，
开个柜子，
拿个药什么的，
超厉害。
但是拥有的技术就意味着我们的社会。
可以顺顺利地卖入老龄化了嘛。
关于这个问题，
我不知道答案，
所以在节目的最后呢，
我想把它作为一个思考的影子留在这儿吧。
真的也非常希望有在从事相关行业。
或做相关研究经验的朋友，
可以在评论区和我们分享一下这间接。
在我们又积极又消极的，
这个聊完了日本养老的医事住行之后，
通过哥，
你这边还有什么想要补充的吗？
我通过这次手术住院啊，
就是不管从金钱还是身心的消耗上，
就是发现自己从根上还是很难改变。
消费社会所养成的这种价值观念，
就是觉得既然投入了，
就应该有正向和实质的回报，
就是花了这么多钱，受这么多罪是吧，
但却很难从一场疾病中收获是吧，
就是甚至很难恢复到生病前的自己，
那衰老这件事其实也是一样的，
就是大家普遍的消费观念，
都是对孩子呢，
会尽可能买高端的产品，
觉得这是积极的面向未来的一个投资，
那老人呢，
也是把自己那点退休金都花在孩子身上了，
但是反过来对于老人，
往往都是收缩性消费，
就是无论是老人，自己还是子女，
都不太愿意花费更高的价格，
买更好的产品，
但是面对越来越严重的老龄化呢，
我们还是需要摆正一个观念，
那就是一个人无论什么年龄，
都应该享有体面的生活，
而且衰老就是一个身体自然退化的过程，
你得学会接受他，
就是不要总是想着自己年轻的时候，
多么健康，精力充沛，
时间也没办法倒流嘛，
那上了年纪也不可怕，
跟人生的每一个阶段一样，
其实都是遇到问题，解决问题，
那同时也要保持自己对生活的热情，
就是无论意识住行，不放弃，不妥协，
一如既往追求自己的之外，
做自己想做的事情。
说得好，
这个人老心不老的经济生，
真的是很重要的。
那在这次的前期资料搜索中呢，
就是意外的发现分析日本养老的文章，
在中文语境里面非常多，
就虽然我们进入老龄化社会的2000年吧，
就是比日本晚了整整30年。
但随着2021年，
中国迈入了深度老龄化阶段，
那这个差距呢在不断缩小，
预计在2035年，
也就是不到10年后，
我们就会进入超级老龄化的最终阶段。
那社会性养老的搭建呢，
就已经迫在眉睫了。
但是翻看这些有关养老的文章呢，
最常提到的，
还是银发族商机这个词，
就是试图快速地找到一条新的赚钱道路。
那随着老龄化的家具，
市场不得不把年轻人的消费重心，
往常年被忽视的这个中老年市场转移。
中老年赛道呢，
也彻底从夹缝市场变成了新澜海。
那这肯定不是坏事儿嘛，
而且是属于市场规律，无可厚非的。
但我们这期也是想说，
在针对老年人的产品开发中，
你除了商机，
是不是能真的解读出这些品牌。
和产品背后的用户需求，
包括开发逻辑，
却了解和清听老年人真正的声音，
而不是凭借单方面的揣测，
去生产一些他们根本用不上的产品，
那更不用说推广到全年龄段了。
那很多人都觉得老年人对品牌的中程度低，
那其实关键还是在于品牌，
是否真的有解决掉他们的痛点？
那为什么斯凯奇转战中老年市场之后深受肯定？
那就是因为他真的足够轻便嘛，
那如果只是想跟风挣点块钱，
不愿意去接触这个群体，
去了解他们真正的需求，
那还谈什么品牌呀，
就是可能只剩了被市场淘汰的份儿了。
那老年呢，
那并不是一个对立的次会，
也不是一个遥不可及的群体，
他就是每一个人自然的发展阶段，
他可以是你的亲人，你的父母，
也会是未来的你自己，
那只有互相倾听，互相理解，
我们才能携手迎来那个真正理想的老龄化社会吧。
其实这期节目做下来，
我个人真的非常非常非常无为杂陈了，
主要的原因呢，
就是因为下个月我要生小孩儿了，
就是一个坏太久月的人在这研究养老，
就有一种说不上来的微妙感呢，
就是你一边在期盼中迎接了新生，
然后一边又在遥望自己的家人，
以及自己的未来。
尤其是前面从某个说到这个。
营发组商机问题，
对应到让我现在非常生物痛觉的母婴消费行业。
我真心觉得什么营发组也好，
母婴也好，
大家本质上都是人啊，
所有的商家出发点，
能不能先把人当人看，
而不是说你反复去利用人性的弱点。
来包装营销概念，
然后去割韭菜，收治上税。
而且虽然我们这期聊的是养老，
但我一直认为说，
不是说你人老了，
才会经历麻烦事儿，对吧。
你这个生活不变，
其实是我们每个人一生中的必经之路的。
你去把这方面的事情做得更好的话，
关乎的是我们自身的处境和利益，
就真是对大家是没有坏处的。
最后最后如前所述，
本人很快就要当妈妈了，
在这里向我亲爱的听众朋友们请一个产假。
一切顺利的话，
我大约会在秋天的时候返场，
毕竟我们连返场之后的这个选题都已经订好了，
就有一种万事俱备的感觉，
就等着小英儿能够放我，
好好做功课，
整理这个资料做节目了。
那在产家这段时间里呢，
我十分十分十分感谢TOMO哥，
他会不定期地推出一些solo节目，
请大家在评论区大声地给出你们的爱的知识，
另外的话呢，
也可以去他的B站账号发光阁的穿上门。
我这边的话，
虽然短期内肯定是没有办法集中精力来做合同这种大投入的节目了，
但是鉴于我这个人总是会有一些意志不住的观察和表达欲，
所以我一个冲动呢，
还注册了一个准备了小孩的节目，
叫做小孩教会我的事，
就用来承载一些我的跟人闲聊吧，
就不想做成什么分享鱼儿心得啊，
或者什么经验那种节目，
我觉得大家都是第一次当家长，
咱也谁都别叫谁做人了。
主要是我觉得说，
通过孕育和养育一个新生命，
其实可以让我们很好的重新理解，
生命究竟是怎么来的，
我们自己倒是怎么长大的。
那有关这方面的无用闲话呢，
我会在那边不定期地随随念一下，
当然大家也可以通过我的公众号。
一大碗沙拉来和我保持电信，
合同这边就请大家等着我满血归来玩，
感谢头某个，感谢大家，
也祝愿头某个做solo节目的时候，
不要丢沙拉死。
那solo的这段时间还请大家多多捧场了，
说不定可以聊点沙拉无福销售的怪谈恐怖主题，
帮助大家清凉的度过夏天。
我该怎么宽你才好呀。
那老规矩，
如果喜欢这期的话，
记得评论，转发，打赏，
那想进去的朋友呢，
可以在收纳水里边找到二维码，
我B站的账号发光格子，
也有动漫作品的分享，
解读，等着大家。
那这期的最后呢，
大家跟我一起预祝沙拉下个月生产顺利吧。
谢谢。
那我们还是下个月solo集，
不见不散吧，
拜拜。
拜拜，秋天见。
我也可以，又不过我姐。
还是那句老话。
既然不是我姐，我就放开了来。
休息之前的，
最后一次你就尽情的来吧。
我就尽情打磕吧，
给了我一个，
那个无限次的刻板圈。
听说太不小拥有了。
刻板放堤。
那车,
先给自己发了一样圈。
每次谁姐，就打刻板真的是。
手握刻板圈。
而教养育乐。
随便剪同伯哥，
没关系，踏实剪。
三二一。